je m'appelle Nils vous pensez ne pas me
connaître et pourtant
il est foutu c'est pas grave
photos il marche encore
parce que je viens d'avoir cet appareil
photo à Noël je me souviens avoir pensé
quand je descendais la piste de ski et
que ma mère me filmait j'en ai marre que
le film tout le temps et je pense que je
vais avoir une marque et le coup c'est
parti en dérapage et après bah gros
pétage de câble de ma mère mais
l'appareil
ah bah c'est bien il est super pour
l'appareil photo génial il est foutu
c'est pas grave
la vidéo sur la chaîne Youtube de
ma sœur elle est trop drôle cette vidéo
je veux que le poumon la voir en fait je
mets pas aussi de la voix je vais
pouvoir la mettre à mes potes et du coup
j'appelle la vidéo ni ce coquin et c'est
comme ça qu'elle a commencé à être sur
internet même si à l'époque elle avait
pas du tout Buzzi c'était un corps enfin
elle avait je sais pas 500 vues en 2013
ou il y a eu le buzz en gros une pote
qui m'envoie un message oh regarde Edwin
aux Zap de spion il a passé la vidéo de
ton frère machin on se dit what the fuck
et après on voit que ça passe ça touche
pas à mon poste et puis fort du Grand
Journal et en fait là la vidéo elle
explose quoi ça c'était le jour en
question avec son air là
il y a une décision que j'ai prise
en arrière
génial tu es vraiment un sale petit con
avec nous mais c'est difficile de d'être
comme ça quand on est une mère parce que
je pense que beaucoup de mer le sont
mais oui mais justement aujourd'hui je
comprends que oui parce qu'effectivement
je vois les mères et je vois qu'elles
ont elles me disent toutes mais on a
tout un moment donné péter un câble
comme ça c'est normal alors que moi à
l'époque je pensais que non j'étais la
seule au début moi j'avais les mères des
copains les enfants qui disaient ah
c'est drôle mais vu la vidéo
super
les gens dans la rue qui disaient elle
veut bravo nul super il savait pas que
j'étais à 100 m 2 mais ça me faisait
rire c'est souvent que des gens
connaissent ou des enfants de copains je
dis oui c'est mon fils Nice et là tu as
les deux ados qui se regardent et qui
disent tu es la mère de Nils et je pense
qu'ils ont fait le tilt avec la voix à
ce moment-là c'était tellement drôle
quoi et dans cette famille ils disaient
toujours fait pas ton Nils je crois que
c'est la première fois depuis que vous
avez posté la vidéo que vous faites une
interview on voit vos visages finalement
c'est la première fois
pour communion on s'est dit que c'était
le bon moment j'ai fait un clip en fait
je fais du rap j'ai sorti un album en
décembre dernier que j'ai appelé génial
en honneur à ma mère et dans album j'ai
fait un son du coup qui s'appelle Abba
c'est bien Nils
t'es vraiment qu'un sale petit con c'est
vrai mais maman a crié peut-être un peu
trop fort car aujourd'hui l'appareil
marche encore on a vu qu'il y avait la
vidéo de de bâtisse salut Maud je vous
me reconnaissez
[Musique]
dit bah ça pourrait intéresser beaucoup
de nous interviewer
c'était pas le moment quoi aujourd'hui
on s'en fout quoi aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
pour moi vraiment c'est la famille c'est
montre la famille skate une famille
est-ce que tu aurais un message pour
tous les Nyx de France je suis vraiment
désolé faut me pardonner j'étais jeune
j'étais un petit con
et j'en avais marre que ma mère me filme
tout le temps donc il y a des stratégies
à lui quoi
c'est bien il est super pour l'appareil
photo génial je te remercie il est foutu
c'est pas grave
tu es vraiment un sale petit con [__]
mais c'est dingue